axios deletes a tweet
in which dr fauci the exalted one peace
be upon him
contradicts vp kamala harris i know this
would be impossible
these are the two most wonderful people
in the country how on earth how could
they possibly be disagreeing
so the left didn't like that axios was
reporting on this so they delete the
tweet
frankly axios is the gold standard of
journalism today compared to
places like the new york times or the
washington post the new york times
you'll recall
when covering the capitol hill riot they
covered this very sad the death of
officer brian sicknick and they reported
that a trump supporter bashed officer
sicknick in the head
with a fire extinguisher right this was
a a
key piece of evidence in the narrative
that was building up about the capital
riot
leading into the impeachment trial of
donald trump
the second impeachment trial of donald
trump i i know that now i have to
specify so the new york times even
though we've known
that the the fire extinguisher story was
complete bunk it wasn't true
no evidence that officer sicknick got
hit in the head with an extinguisher
they would not retract the story we've
now known this for a long time they
would not retract the story
until conveniently right after the
impeachment trial of trump
drats they didn't get them there was
there was no way they were going to
convict
unfortunately trump gets to live to see
another political day
so the new york times finally admits the
story was bogus they say quote update
new information has emerged regarding
the death of the capital police officer
brian sicknick that questions the
initial cause
of his death provided by officials close
to the capitol police
okay but they actually had to rewrite
the the initial article because
what we were told was law enforcement
officials initially said
mr siknik was struck with a fire
extinguisher but weeks later
police sources and investigators were at
odds over whether
he was hit and medical experts say he
didn't die of blunt force trauma so
therefore you know
up this is according to one law
enforcement official so what is it
is it official is it law enforcement
officials or officials
close to the capitol police
this would seem to matter you know it
seems like minor details but when you're
talking about
the death of this officer during this
riot that is being used as
the single piece of evidence this riot
in the impeachment of
a former president that in itself
unprecedented don't you think you should
be specific on the details
but no it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter don't you think
when you're talking about things i mean
i guess kind of ties in more broadly to
what we're talking about today
global warming science the apocalypse
coming upon us right we've got 12 years
of the world is going to end
the left tells us some leftists tell us
it's going to end even sooner unless we
do exactly what they say
and give them the power but they're
never really specific is the world going
to end because
it's going to get a lot colder and we're
going to have a new ice age like they
told us in the 70s
and that's why we have to give them all
this new power or is the world going to
end
because the earth is warming and it's
going to be really really hot
and that's why we have to give them all
the same powers or is the world maybe
not not exactly warming maybe there's
sort of a pause going on in the warming
and actually you know the polar bears
are doing just fine and actually the
arctic ice doing
basically just fine so it's remaining
more or less
the same as it ever was but that
that as well as evidence that the world
is going to end we have to give them all
this new power don't you think the
details matter
when you're talking about fundamentally
reordering society constitutional
government
uh property rights all all these very
important facets of our society
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you